i was dealing with this is a few months
back i was dealing with a question of
stupid topic but the meaning of life
right what's the meaning how could that
be stupid though well it says trite it's
trite you're not supposed to think about
it it's something you ask your parents
when you're young they tell you don't
worry about it or they still get a job
yeah exactly get a job you freaking
hippy or here's god god is the meaning
of life right and so i was just trying
to resolve for myself like what could
the answer be right not what is the
answer but what could the answer be
and so at a core level i was forced to
kind of hunt down all these weird little
things and really understand for myself
and it's got to be personal right but i
have to establish for myself what it
could and could not be
and that gave me some level of peace
so now i don't have to keep asking that
question what is the meaning of life
i mean you you sh i think the question
is more interesting than the answer
everyone should explore this on their
own but let me just explore a few parts
with you right
so first is if i gave you an answer if i
said the meaning of life is to please
god well which god okay judeo-christian
god well okay why that one why this
thing the problem is it's a why question
you can keep asking why forever right
any answer i give you you'll just ask
why again why again
that's right and you end up in a place
called agrippa's trilemma okay this is a
philosophical exercise but i i kind of
thought it through then googled around
and there's a thing called agrippa's
trilemma
and agrippa's trauma says that any
questioning like this why will always
end in one of three places okay first is
infinite regress
right why because of this why that what
and just keep going forever
the second is circular reasoning well a
why a because of b or why b because of a
right you get trapped in that or the
third is an axiom and the most popular
axiom is god but it could be anything
because of math because of science
because the big bang because the
simulation right these are all axioms
these are all just stopping points
saying simulation we're in a simulation
or saying it's the big bang is just
another way of saying god it's just
god's a dirty word so we don't use it as
much anymore but same thing so you end
up in one of these three dead ends
essentially right so
there is no answer uh the real answer is
because
right what is the meaning of life yeah
you get to make up your own answer is
the beauty if there was a single answer
we would not be free we would be trapped
because then we would all have to live
to that answer then we'd be bored like
robots each one competing with each
other to fulfill that single meaning
more than the others back to signaling
like i'm better at it than you are but
luckily there is no answer so you just
do whatever you want
the meaning of life
it's funny that
that what that's the basis of all
existential angst that you don't
you don't know why you're here and you
have this feeling that it could be
meaningless
it is i mean if you
when you start pondering the
the multiverse the universe the galaxies
the solar system the planet the organism
the cells inside the organism the
bacteria the parasites right the
symbiotic relationship we have to our
environment and you start going jesus
christ what am i just a little piece of
this thing it's like well the answers to
all the great questions are paradoxes
yeah so for example you're asking like
do i matter that's like really the
question you asked right well how do i
matter in this infinite universe well
you know on the one hand you're separate
no two points are the same every point
is every two points are infinitely
different you're completely separated no
one will have your thoughts your
emotions your feelings your experience
so your life is a single player game
you're trapped inside your head and
you're just aware of a bunch of things
going on and that's it
on the other hand
i cannot say the word joe rogan without
invoking the entire universe joe alien
comes along says what's that joe rogan
what's joe rogan's a human what's a
human bipedal ape what's an ape on the
earth what's the earth planet what's a
planet solar system where was the carbon
made inside stars right instead i have
to create the entire universe
to just say the words joe rogan so in
that sense you're connected to
everything it's inseparable so
the answer to that question of do i
matter is i am nothing and i am
everything and you'll find this with all
the great questions the answers are all
paradoxes which is why at some level
it's sort of pointless to pursue them to
find a trite answer like i'm giving but
the act of pursuing them is actually
really useful because then it gives you
certain intrinsic understanding in your
life that brings a level of peace
i feel like there's with many people
this
stress of this question is also
accentuated by unhappy lives it's
actually accentuated by unhappy choices
by being trapped there's a big
difference between not knowing what the
meaning of life is and
god i gotta get the [ __ ] out of this job
i have to i can't live my life this way
what's the meaning of life if this is my
life which is why i always start with
let's get you rich first
right that's why i'm very practical
about it because look
you know buddha was a prince okay he
started out really rich and then he got
to go off in the woods
and in the old days what happened was if
you wanted to be peaceful inside you
would become a monk you would renounce
everything you would become an ascetic
you would give everything up you
renounce women men you'd renounce
children you'd announce money you'd
renounce politics science technology
everything and you would go out in the
woods by yourself you to give everything
up to be free inside
well today we have this wonderful
invention called money where you can
just store stuff up in a bank account
okay and you can basically
save up you can you can work really hard
you can do great things for society and
society will give you money for giving
it things that it wants and it doesn't
know how to get
and then you can save that up and you
can live well below with your means and
you can find a certain freedom in that
and that will give you the time and the
energy to pursue your own internal peace
and happiness
so i believe the solution to making
everybody happy is to give them what
they want let's get them all rich let's
get them all fit and healthy and then
let's get them all happy
at the end of the day i i do think even
despite what i said earlier life is
really a single-player game it's all
going on in your head you know whatever
you think you believe
will very much shape your reality both
from what risks you take and what
actions you perform but also just your
everyday experience of reality if you're
walking down the street and you're
judging everyone you're like i don't
like that person because their skin
color i don't like that oh she's she's
not attractive that guy's fat this
person's a loser oh who put this in my
way uh you know
the more you judge the more you're going
to separate yourself and you'll feel
good for an instant because you'll feel
good about yourself i'm better than that
but then you're going to feel lonely and
then you're just going to see negativity
everywhere the world just reflects your
own feelings back at you reality is
neutral
reality has no judgments to a tree
there's no concept of right or wrong or
good or bad right you're born you have a
whole set of sensory experiences and
stimulations and lights and colors and
sounds and then you die yeah and how you
choose to interpret that is up to you
you do have that choice so this is what
i meant that happiness is a choice if
you believe it's the choice then you can
start working on it and i can't tell you
how to find it because
it's your own conditionings that are
making you unhappy so you have to
uncondition yourself it's just like i
can't fix your eating habits for you can
give you some general guidelines but you
got to go through the hard habit forming
of how to eat right but you have to
believe it's possible and it is
absolutely possible i was miserable i'm
happy as a clam it's not just the money
i got there before the money
[Music]
[Music]
so
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
[Music]
you